german football association chose the
French Embassy a fitting location in
Berlin for the unveiling of their euro
2016 preliminary roster fans on hand
already had names in mind looking from
definitely Mario götze and Manuel Neuer
Gomez of course gomez is a safe choice
she should have eyes it's important to
me that Schweinsteiger is named today
I'm surprised that podolsky is still in
the process Lukas Podolski was indeed
included he's a seasoned vet like the 13
other rule champions love is relying on
the experienced players to help guide
the newcomers to success such as schalke
08 a yahshua Kimmage from bayern iulian
brought from Leverkusen when Dortmund
Julian vagal one or the other had been
contacted early in the morning but all
were extremely excited it's a big goal
for young players to just be in the
tournament I think they know there is a
lot you can learn from those already on
the national team you could feel their
emotions on the phone before you dispute
mundo steady for Captain Bastian
Schweinsteiger also received a call
despite being sidelined due to a knee
injury but the midfielder has been
progressing he can already put full
weight on his knee we have to see when
he can start training with us whether
next week is possible or not if it's too
much for Bastion then we have to decide
on who will be captain it wasn't right
and that carpet inside them yogi love
will have only one friendly match before
deciding who the final 23 players will
be for euro 2016